oh mio dio andò via altri otto
centimetri di media e minori è forse
esagerato
[Musica]
il parma ci hanno abbandonato il nido a
30 gen
[Musica]
qui e per tutto aido con il a perosa lo
sentono
[Musica]
gorilla peluso al rapporto pagina dei
denti tutta fatto fatina dei denti a
rapporto non trovo il barbagianni e che
tramite cavolo
[Musica]
adesso quindi che no mi vendicherò siamo
il palco
[Musica]
è importante che tu sei che la cosa è
sveglia e sa come faccia mi dà fastidio
per i vestiti però in realtà è che ce ne
vuole tra mare e siamo arrivati al
momento che tutti quanti dobbiamo
sentire ovini la testa io ti denuncio
avevamo detto alle persone di mettere
dei like sotto al video di cucinare
della pasta della pagina ogni decina di
migliaia di like sarebbero stati
vicentine trovato a venderti a quanto
stiamo vediamo ma tanta mida like
ragazzi i complimenti di uno di non
chiedere video normali di prenderci 20
30 a pagarli oro quando si tratta di rom
pericoli come tutti a cliccare sono
orgoglioso di voi io come un tantino ora
andrò a tagliargli i capelli che furtiva
ce l'hai bel kit professionale posso
dire che in realtà non ho tanta paura di
guglielmo esiste sempre un barbiere
proprio questo momento io me ne voleva
st maglietta si sentono la pc come
mettete un drive ogni decina di migliaia
di reich nel prossimo video già partito
per attuare un indumento ti posso far
vedere una referenza questo sto cercando
è così rasati li hai tu di sodio cioè
nel senso io ti posso fare ma non c è di
san donatese competenze vulcano c'era
come in questo modo 8 cm me rilevi tutti
ci sia voglia questo se ce la fai che mi
tengo comunque una lunghezza fatto ma
ora sono comandate mediante non è voluta
negli anni venti centimetri sono i miei
capelli dibatterà sia in questi sono
otto centimetri
soltanto in pochi si sono 80 ma ancora
che ha poi un doppio taglio pazzesco se
sia al parrucchiere mi si dica si o
quello cha bicipite cembra ma la gente
indovina i vostri visibili
gli ordini non hanno unito io manco io
iniziare a tagliare scusatemi gianmarco
di dare un taglio agile veloce se ci
stanno le persone che tagliano i capelli
e che sono bra vendita delle dritte dopo
quando sarà finito mi leggere commenti
ed io avrei potuto fare meglio che
questo e quest'altro a me dispiace che
il mio barbiere di fiducia di anna ciao
stefano cosa stai facendo è un attimo in
serie a sezionare la tua testa regala
cosa bella chi non mi vedo neanche di
solito si ha uno scatto è vero tu alla
guida diventerai resiste in più
teletubbies fermo dei saperlo ma resta
mi sto fatta i miei capelli da guglielmo
ii è strano che tu cominci da quel punto
è cominciata la pensata chi ama è lui
che gara ti vedo perplesso linea non
vedete un meccanismo super efficiente
capitano io direi il sen etico in cui
più corti e qui tutti i lunghi si può
fare un taglio e tutto quanto
il supporto di giovanna d'arco per
l'altra nella hai un bel capello robusto
piacevole da tagliare e anche augusto mi
raccomando per favore non abbassa la
testa pensando meta che non è del tutto
bislacco non mi va di stare su con il
furetto che ti guardi attorno e non di
brutte non vedo stare fermo del
conflitto possibilità col si configura
base dove merito rilevare i piedi sul
pezzo come dovresti stare fermo diciamo
che a 50 100mila line o 50 80 per i
capelli 100.000 likers vi prego fate
meno serie pari sto diventando la
cultura del web
cosa fareste per 100.000 light si faccia
una serietà non va bene che gioco solo
io a questo gioco giusto giocare anche
voi ha mai ragione mamme non vengono in
mente dei vestiti importanti come la
serenità comprati un paio di hogan e
facci in giro per una settimana però
quella federico enrico 100.000 like deve
mangiare un piatto assaggiato da qualcun
altro ha mai lasciare un piatto
assaggiato da nonna ma si stanno
accorciando si vede un po di differenza
rispetto a prima
noi come tahiri tenendo il suo lavoro
fino ad adesso ha confuso dell'unità
sicuro più parti
ma tu sei un falegname che succedono
qui mi sento non può assumere i riflessi
e adesso come si fa non mi fai paura io
adesso dato di macchinetta johnny è suo
la forza tecnica davvero lentissima
proprio applicativo sarà un senso lo so
esattamente cosa sto facendo
controlliamo la simmetria al momento sei
nemo quindi in offerta per aggiustare un
paio di cose è un ottimo capello tesoro
ma ce l'hai la sempre sempre cosa quella
di che si passava sul collo certo c'è
pure il borotalco e poi o il casco
secondo diventerà il vino di rinfresco
[Applauso]
insomma giallo adattarti hai fatto che è
buonissima e l'attacco video ancora non
è uscito al vero sai mai veramente
pericolosi sembri boromir dai capelli
lunghissimi allora pensavo peggio
secondo me il gruppo è andare pure il
più corto sui lati a mi dà il permesso
al farlo ti do il permesso
potresti avere un ei capelli di justin
bieber che in questo momento abbiamo
registi carroccio prova a fare o paypal
prima firma non è accessibile come non è
justin bieber di spirito e di prendersi
pure può sembrare tommy jean ping non lo
so perché non ho mai visto nel caso in
cui non ti piacesse e dunque noi saper
indossare questo che gli costò nomi
valenzana altobello con lavandaia si
sapeva ma devo ancora sfumare qui bravo
e fortunato to the man detto che questa
è la prima volta che io intanto con una
consapevolezza nuova devo essere sincero
io dico io me su una scodella in testa
giusto per ricordarlo ed è stato un
momento magico iconico dati del nostro
canale per questo vi saremo eternamente
grati se non ti piacciono
picchio che w che dire che tv ha bisogno
ogni tanto mi sento la macchinetta che
ne l'orecchio e di conseguenza nel
cervello comunque c'è marco e da versare
in serenità di più tra tutte le persone
ai quali ho fatto i capelli e consumate
nei fatti solo a lui
[Risate]
8 reti infettivi testimoniato per te
vaccinare ok che c'è quella lapide con
la pena capitale
il discorso è identico iengo bravin
secondo già 8 santo dire che ho preso
una dimestichezza dell'ennesimo
guglielmo bravo ancora a lato puoi fare
la sua matura per farmi lo boccia
servivano 200.000 like passi con la tua
depilazione gianni a 100.000 light ed
una settimana non riguarda con la faccia
da psicopatico tetto mila rai 4 la
settimana ma io ti sto salendo perché ce
n'è troppo basta aiutando così tanto
questa sfumatura facce vedevo dire viene
un pò mozzato qua guarda lì pronti
convincere convince
[Musica]
questa sbagliato qualcosa di troppo in
questa zona qui vedi che c'è uno scalino
rispetto agli altri c'è una vertigine
hai un errore nella festa ma è una cosa
della mia testa purtroppo mi capita
anche che quando merito io dai
professionisti
a questi andrebbero quasi non ti dico 0
anche il dr e al doppio taglio
e allora meglio che fosse così
l'obiettivo a queste frasi sono perde un
po di equilibrio non voglio dire ton cup
ore possiamo confermato quindi in cosa
la william una cammino deposto di che
pensavo molto peggio
e poi se tu mi ste cose impazzisco cosa
che è successo perché poi tu devi fare
così e aggiustare non l avrei voluto
fare qualcosa antonio di più graduale ma
sono molto contento di forbici ma i
ragazzi fatemi sapere cosa ve ne pare se
ho fatto cagare col mio primo tempino
feitor se è passabile se ci sono dei
consigli mettete un like questo video lo
facciamo apparire il vecchio mercato
attentivo facciamo l'apparire legni con
fare un qualcosa che bolle regole questo
nome scrivete via questo canale attivate
la campanella delle notifiche mettete
like se volete vedere gianmarco depilato
con la ceretta va la mia noi ci vediamo
giovedì alle 14 con un nuovo video ciao
dai come giusto che stia facendo
sempre che è un collo infinito ma in
cognitivi piedino della valle incantata
e siccome abbiamo infilare sotto una
doccia è a casa e ho fatto un bel lavoro
comunque torinese conti niente va
benissimo dare andata è andata